Hey
Roofer 13 Moving
Azuma
[Applause]
I
have no eyesight, but I look ahead to the owner of
people.  Let me tell you
that voodoo
It's an example me
Why are you kidnapping me and what are you going to do with me?I'm
just a hostage Is
everyone serious?
When I flew to see it, I happened to find Keihai at Toei If you
think life will go your way, you should
lose to me and study
I'll tell you something interesting
.
inverse yeah yeah
rar It's a copy of
death and death
20 'cause
this is the Liberal Democratic Party's rare I
want you to buy me a new technique that
combines nanban I fell in love with you so much while the enemy was hesitant to attack
I was
entertained
r
Eh
par